and there it is  history russell westbrook has just  surpassed  oscar robertson it lasted 47 years  and now russell westbrook stands there  all alone  a record that was titled untouchable for  47 years  has been broken congratulations russell  westbrook  russell westbrook did something that  nobody  thought was possible  he's been described as not human well  he's now the all-time triple double  leader with 182  and the wizards have cut it to four  [Applause]  15 nothing run  i mean just unreal  that we've all been able to witness  the history in the making and now that  record  being broken and they just announced it  in the arena  at state farm arena the wizards players  applaud the fans applaud and there's  russell westbrook looking up he did it  and look it's nothing to him he knows  that he doesn't have time  to take anything for granted the crowd  in atlanta channing ross saul raw salt